I get those goosebumps every time I need
time throw that to this aisle I can't
use on Sabri what is up guys today's
moneymaker requires no requirements and
it's super easy to do so let's go ahead
and get into it so I just put an offer
in for 8,000 cooking apples and 200
baskets and so what we're going to be
doing is making the cooking apples
filling the baskets and then making
apples 5s which sell for a profit of
like 2.3 K so we should be making pretty
good money so I'm going to do a thousand
of them and start the timer and then I
will show you guys what I get one sec
let me set it up so 20 and put these
back in okay and now I will start the
timer and go
[Music]
you
and okay so now I finished it I did 200
of them with a thousand apples and it
took out crap I'll have to look at that
and figure out the time once I think is
like we'll just say it was like 635 so
we'll go ahead and go to the history so
I hints and sold them sauce Henson's
helm again
alright so muslim' sold so I'll just
wait for those to sell but while they
are selling I will do the math so they
should sell for a total of 168 200 so
we'll go ahead and do the math real
quick so 168 200 minus 108 zero zero
zero minus these 600 from the baskets so
I made about 70 K in six minutes so I
will wait for those a cell and then do
some more mouths so they haven't sold
yet but I went ahead and looked back at
the footage and it took six minutes and
20 seconds to get 60 K so we're checking
around this for 60 K so we're going to
do 60 minutes divided by 6 and a half
minutes 9.2 so we're going to times that
by 60 K so you can make 553 k if you
could get your clicks right you can make
more than that my arm is starting to get
a little tired so I don't recommend
doing this for an hour but if you just
want to make it quick like hundred K you
can just do more than 200 and make it
these will sell I'm sure they will I
mean I instantly sold these already it's
not that I mean if you have to wait
it'll be like maybe 5 minutes or
something so it's no big deal but
anyways the reason why these sell is
because people use them for farming and
I was just going to use them for farming
but I couldn't buy any so I was like oh
maybe it's you were to make them so I
made them and then decided to sell them
and saw that you can make money so
anyways you can make 550 K an hour with
no requirement I hope you guys like this
video thanks for watching guys stay
tuned for next video
Oh